hi my name is Eric Zacapa I work at the
center of research of the French
military academy of sincere this talk is
about visualizing classifying modeling
in game data from the planning component
of the artificial intelligence and genes
of six commercial first-person shooters
and that's it
so the talk is a package for game AI
planning analytic so I'll explain all
that planning may I plan ingame AI
planning my name is Eric Eric Jacopo I
work at the center of research at the
French military academy of sassier the
main difference with the u.s. that there
is only one military academies in France
where us
that's quite a bunch in the US and it's
located in the in Brittany ok abstract
so I describe that package have been
developing for the past four years as a
package itself but I've got plenty of
functions for now ten years the
objective is to analyze in-game data
from the planning component of an AI
engine artificial intelligence and jeno
the commercial video game and I also
briefly address Mathematica package
development if we ever at the time so I
begin with the goals of that work so in
terms of research my primary goal is to
characterize game AI planning so that
gaming I get my developers find it
easier to use game AI planning in their
video game project so as a researcher it
means that my questions come from game
developers not from me just I try to
listen to them I not a cannot get their
doors and and I I do ask them questions
and from from what they tell me and from
the discussions then I try to set goals
for my own research the objective for
that package there are many actually but
one side of game AI planning an analytic
is to visualize and classify that's
usual analytics right visualizing
classifying and modeling I won't show
you anything about Marlene in game AI
planning type data all right another
side of characterizing game AI planning
is to provide metrics for assessing the
performance of gave me AI planning
components
in a video game so think of it
commercial games are extremely expensive
they now you studios now spend hundreds
of millions of dollars on only one game
and the idea is to of course reduce both
the amount of money spent and the time
there so it's not business as usual but
project development as usual and project
management so the idea is to come up
with metrics so that you can reduce both
time and money on such huge projects
this presentation the objective is to
show the kind of visualization and
classification and report on my
experience my sad experience unpackaged
development with Mathematica ok so let
me start with planning what it is
planning so I just noticed that in this
building we those two that's the very
first one of the two two things here you
can that's a plan actually in terms of
psychology cognitive psychology that
wouldn't be a plan but let's say that's
a plan because it's that's exactly
what's happening in a game you can see
here goes right the stairs it says so
you stairs which means that you have to
do a little processing there stare right
here and stare right here like me on
that side stares and stares and if
you're here right you there are two
plans for you then walk turn to left
walk walk and then new stairs or there
is no turn to right which is very
interesting but walk walk walk walk walk
walk and then use that stare far right
okay so that's the idea of planning
that's more path planning than just
action planning because I had to explain
those arrows and transform the goal the
stairs into into a go to put it in in
the format of what happens in a game
another
emergency exit plan okay so you can see
I'm among the first third floor so my
room is right here so it's on every
every door in every room that's one of
the plan
so plans currently are almost everywhere
right and this is a prospective plan it
should be in the future planning is
about the future but planning can be
also about the past right if you want to
explain what happened
all right so game AI planning gimme I'm
planning planning well that's an
artificial intelligence technique it's
been invented in 1968 which means it's
almost as old as AI actually the very
first AI program GPS general problem
solver use planning but at the time
there the vocabulary wasn't there but
the use action they used means and
analyzes and things like that and ten
years later the Stanford research
problem solver which was the Institute I
for Institute a problem solver was
invented to produce planned to build
plans for a robot so what do plan look
like well if you remember those
evacuation plan we had a five action
plan walk turn to walk walk and you'll
then use stairs but you know in a game
it's more a plan like that go to inspect
and threaten no it means starting in a
place okay you go to a new inspect how
do you do that well when you arrive
there is what is called a smart object
you just download an animation into the
character and then that character
inspects the area and then he threatens
the area for some reason okay give me
our planning so remember that a I plan
was invented per se in 1968 a game AI
planning was born in in 2005 when Jeff
working then a master student at MIT
and hired by monolith studio decided to
implement to use strips in a game at the
time the previous game which was titled
no one lives forever was a hit and they
wanted to improve the AI again to push
it further and they decided to use a
planner to control the behaviors of non
player characters that was the first
time so it's um it's only been there
gave me a planning since 2005 so this
very first gave me a planner was called
dope goal-oriented action planning and
since fear there's been quite a lot of
games using dope to control on PC
behaviors okay
another planning algorithm got
implemented by Guerrilla Games guerrilla
games but so monolith is that is in
Seattle but guerrilla games is in
Amsterdam Netherlands they used
hierarchical task networks to implement
planning won't explain that just give an
example in a few minutes so that's the
example go builds plans from actions go
to inspect threaten okay so that's a
plan and go to is an action inspectors
in action threaten is an action and
action planning brittle builds plans
form macro actions so that plan go to
inspect threaten you can see that as a
patrol plan so what HTN planning does it
instead of trying each action find lower
grant actions go to inspect threaten it
tries course grand action big bigger
grand actions such as patrol and if this
patrol action as is applicable in the
current situation then it is decomposed
in those small free actions okay which
games since 2005 so it's just a brief
sum up of the game so you can see the
fear hierarchy here fear to and all
these games you can see that these games
are mostly or are or combat games there
are first-person shooters
right just so let's see monolith just
goes to was implemented in Sweden and
transformer as in hymen studio and in
San Jose a deus ex by Eidos Montreal and
Tomb Raider was implemented by Crystal
Dynamics in south of San Francisco okay
go versus HTN planning some video games
using HT ends so you can see the
Killzone series here and they stopped
the Killzone series a guerilla game and
they their last game is horizon zero
dawn which has highly suggest to play
horizon life is strange and horizon as
well Dark Soul which is I don't suggest
you to play duck song it's a very
difficult game a total war and napoleons
just for fun it's a bad bad planner and
the very last I'd say very last game of
the diamond light series and I used a
sham planning as well htm' planning is
slightly decreasing in the game
community gave me a community where a
scope is is widely used these days okay
so data so there are so usual things
about data analytics right we collect we
extract and we visualize we visualize we
classify not classify in terms of
classifying in terms of comparing not in
terms of learning right and modeling
okay so game analytics whereas it means
we've got generally a bunch of players
right the idea is just to know why
those players bought my game and they
did not even install it right there is
this huge games servers Amazon like
Steam for instance and on Steam the
number of games per per account is 70 so
on average people are praying at most 10
or 12 right I'm having 18 games and I'm
playing 5 or 6 games okay okay and then
you crunch and then you get two things
money you explain why people are playing
or not playing the game and then you got
hit maps just on the below hit maps
telling you telling the players were to
put where when you play sniper where you
should be or where you should put your
machine-gun or where you should throw
your drones on the enemy and all these
things ok so cunning analytics what does
that mean you got a plan engine instead
of inside of a game engine which is
himself which inside you also have an AI
artificial intelligence and game engine
right you have a game state sorry I'm
going this way as well how is games to
define it's a vector of values distance
distance too complicated no no that
would be distance to some other
characters only at some point within a
radius for instance okay and short
radius because what you have to know
what you have to please have in mind
that's the time budget because games are
real-time systems it's extremely
important to have that in mind right
games are our real-time systems and the
time budget so everything is this is
design it's a it's a placement problem
right
how much time you give to your component
and the planning component can get at
most 10% of a frame so when when it's 30
frames per second it means about 33
milliseconds for one frame on screen and
10% of that is about 3mm
seconds okay but planning is just one
part of AI right there is past planning
there is like line of sight there is
threat detections and all these things
so it's it's again about 10% of those
three milliseconds which means it's
point three milliseconds per frame
that's that's quite a lot all right
planning analytics so on average what
the game community is doing and the
schedule of money on that is maximizing
the value of player data right these
days you have online games with millions
of accounts and millions of players so
we want to know where they died we want
to know where and what they do and and
why we're trying to give actions to
interpret their sequence of move to
detect their intent and what they want
to do and we're trying to maximize that
and offer them actually not offer them
but getting some money from that okay
and what we want to do what I want to do
is just the thing on the side its
maximize the value of planning data
right so over the years I've been able
to extract some to get some data from
commercial games that's something which
is extremely difficult to do because
games are IPS or intellectual properties
right so which means when you knock for
instance at monoliths to do it means you
end up eight months after in an office
in Hollywood and you have a lawyer in
front of you and it explains everything
but you shouldn't do with the data that
they might be giving you so it's quite
it's quite strange but it's quite a
fight to get some kind of data it takes
approximately two years so when you
first knock at the door and you get some
data it's been two years mostly right
okay so what does it look like so I'll
show you the data well those two I got
several but I give you the first two
only
okay Harry skills on free data from
Transformers okay so you can see it
begins with a timestamp then the name of
the NPC so you can see what it looks
like where is this one I just don't
remember okay you can see the plan the
plan was remember active plan you can
see just a move all right it's about
it's probably a that's a drone that's a
drone okay and 1032 1033 1034 and so on
is just numbers of nav meshes so that
the drone can move over the player okay
so you can see that the time stamp here
is a big number it's because the number
of ticks per second is somewhat very
strange actually
guerilla games is a Sony studio so
they're producing games on on ps3
playstation 3 and and the produced games
on possession for um possession for
which means there was no way at all that
one was on the free no way at all to
export files so they did a very specific
line X version of the game and the only
reliable real-time clock they were able
to have add that number of ticks per
second so so you can see the differences
between the data which means it's some
kind of girl analytics as well when you
get some kind of data you say okay I
like something more this and these for
instance I like the NPC location and
then you don't get it
so in the next one you can see the NPC
location that's the triple of of numbers
right here but you can see that this
time the time stamp has nothing to do
with the previous one and I've included
this data because I think it's quite fun
that someone didn't make a description
torus value so there are bugs in
software yes
which one this one those three values
are the position X Z Y of that character
in the game yes I'll say yes but I'm not
sure because it might be that there mmm
might be several origins yes of course
oh yes oh yes okay more data again so if
you love the package and you you know
the files from the game then you could
do some kind of planning analytics so I
can speak forever I was an idiot small
trail last week and I spoke all day so
on those kind of data so if you there
something you like the most I can speak
on something more and less than
something else which one really like if
you have no idea at all I'll pick up one
topic actions cost and usage that's it
all right so let's go actions cost and
usage action cost
I'll begin with action cast all right so
action cost so strangely you can see
that so action cast why do you have
actions Gaussian in game so the idea is
is just to put attached a number to each
action so that the search for the plan
will be something like find the least
cost plan okay you want to achieve a
goal all right so you can walk there
okay and walk there will will be custody
for some reason or you can fly there and
it might be even more Kirstie and then
adding the cost of the actions then
you'll find a cost for the plan and then
you sort out of these obvious costs and
and you'll find the least cost plan
alright so you can see here how it looks
like
that's the cost distributions for fear
some shadow of mordor and the - murderer
games so you can see that they look the
same right these games have the first
two on the Left I've been done by two
differ by the same Studios but the
second a shadow of model right here and
the last tier 11 which is Tomb Raider
were designed by two different Studios
and because distributionally the same
right
that's Tomb Raider which means it's one
character in third-person view and it's
the Tomb Raider series a serie and
shadow of mordor so it's one your
character against only a few and in
shutoff mode or it's your character
against several tens of NPCs right but
it's anyhow the costs are the same all
right action cost versus action news
edge that's an interesting one
okay I'll stop there okay first no I'll
don't take this one I'm sorry
yes shadow more so I take this one and
you can see so what's on the x axis the
x axis is action usage okay so one
action appears so you take over that I
have and one action appears about 20% of
the time this one right the one on the
far right okay and the action cost you
can see that the action cost is about
free right so they had this this
question for me discussing with them
they said Eric could you we try to treat
the cost the action cost so that some
actions appear more often on screen
because we think that some action is
more important for the player than
others could you check that the least
cost actions appear more often on screen
well obviously that's not the case right
you can see very costly actions here
okay and you can see least cast actions
and and they're less used than those
actions right here okay and that's again
the case for this action right here ok
it's 2 times more expensive than this
one and this one is less use than this
one okay suddenly seven percent of the
time and five percent of the time but
apparently action cost you can at week
action cost to modify the player
immersion and experience you tweak
action cost only for the search the
search for plan that's all what you can
do okay I could show you yes this one as
well this one should be there and and
this one should be should be there as
well and those those ones should be
hahaha somewhere here yeah I know I know
I know it does you have to think that a
a game designer is somebody constraining
inventing patterns right invents
patterns of interactions between the
player and and the game right the level
designer just designed the levels so
that those patterns can occur at some
point during the level and then they're
implemented spawning of NPCs is
implemented by by the game programmers
but it's extremely precise right for
instance at first test of the level it's
the game designer replaces the level if
it doesn't see what's very what's on the
game design document is going to be
really mad really mad so and it's real
different for everyone just to please
the kind of pattern
which was designed for the spirit of the
game you know that's when you say a game
is violent
for instance stick rage by its software
it's one of the most violent game I know
I mean you think Doom is violets game
eat software as well doom doom is
violent but no it's not the case play a
rage and then you'll see well how do you
implement this violence violent
experiments violent immersions alright
so think of it play play rage play doom
and then you see but exactly same it
software game right but rage is it tries
to eat you really it's it's dangerous
game okay maybe leaf anyway alright so
I'm going to show you something more I'm
gonna yes sir
okay action cast cumulative actions
plant stability oh yes plants stability
yeah I'm gonna no too complicated for
plum frequencies or NPCs I'm sorry NPCs
what session casting what does it look
like what does a level look like okay it
doesn't want to show me the session
casting okay that's it okay so here is a
session casting right so what does it
means that's the the session for kids on
free the 13 minute I had so a dot right
here is represent a plan at some point
in the game okay and one line represent
so series of dots on one line represent
an NPC so on the y-axis you get NPCs and
you got time on the x-axis so what you
see here is exactly what is designed in
terms of level and patterns of
interactions right you walk you
encounter a drones and then you walk and
it's kind of cool and then you fight you
fight you fight and Anthony you walk
more and then enemies are our spawn and
then maybe you take a lift or another
or you walk even more and then enemies
again that long yellow line is a sniper
very difficult to kill and a very long
red line is the you're AI companion
there are some AI companions from time
to time in the game and I want to show
you that one those two if I may
all right that's from I've selected it
AI companion it means it helps you it
suggests things to do for you no not
screenshot it talks to you or it does
things and then you suddenly you play it
where is it oh it's here what is it
doing and then you suddenly realize it's
kind of doing some kind of problem
solving but it's up to you to do it or
not
yeah so where are these useful for these
may be useful for that so I've shown you
those this very long red line on the
previous session casting so if you see
and and tell you it's an AI body so
those two lines orange and green you'd
say well these are AI bodies as well
no they're rats okay that's the bug okay
they're rats if you go you and counter
internals rats if you don't kill them
well they've just forgot to de-spawn
them to remove them you get out of the
tunnel and you keep walking they're two
kilometers away from you there's just no
way for you to see those well they just
forget to dismember the NPCs so that's a
way to find also bugs in the game